[Music]
the zombies characters are colorful and
fun to watch but we wanted to get to
know the cast a little better so we
compiled a list of our favorite Johnny's
cast members from youngest to oldest can
you guess which one is the oldest you'll
have to watch to find out if you're new
here subscribe to the things to catch
all our new videos and click the like
button if you like zombies as much as we
do
Kingston Foster Kingston Foster he plays
Jed's younger sister was born on July 26
2010 making her the youngest zombies
cast member
Kingston's birthday falls within the Leo
horoscope sign this means she is very
outgoing and loves people
Leo's can be pretty dramatic making them
perfect for the spotlight you can tell
by Kingston's warm smile that she is a
sincere friend and a family-oriented
person she's a born leader and very
independent even if she is young not
that you need any more reasons to love
Kingston but we found out a few fun
facts about her her middle name is news
kingston news foster has a nice ring to
it
she loves karaoke baking muffins and
cookies and hair selling she also loves
to travel and he's been out of the
country three times this talented zombie
has even learned to sew she said she
made a purse once also her favorite food
is macaroni and cheese
Milo Manheim next on our list is the
star of the film and who zombie football
players dad big birthday is on March 6
2001 which makes him the Pisces Pisces
people tend to be witty and energetic
yep that fits my lone Pisces are also
big dreamers and tend to be attracted to
their opposites that fits right in with
his storyline on the film don't you
think here's some more juicy tidbits
about Milo he's a huge Harry Potter fan
and says he would give anything to be a
wizard at Hogwarts he also said that if
he wasn't an actor she would be a chef
and loves watching Gordon Ramsay on
YouTube Milo admitted that she is still
sometimes afraid of the dark a zombie
who's afraid of the dark now we've seen
everything
as for Milo's favorite Disney villain he
said hands down it's Ummah from
descendants - she says she makes it
impossible to hate her
meg Donnelly meg Donnelly is third on
our list her birthday is July 25th 2000
we owe in the house Leo's are passionate
and creative they love having
but treasure family time - he'll never
meet a person with more ambition than
OEO
and they love a good argument we know
Meg Donnelly as Addison and zombies but
let's get to know the actress a little
better mag is pretty athletic
she loves surfing hiking and boxing
she's really into science and museums
her snowman-building skills aren't quite
at the anna and elsa level that she does
a pretty good job she also loves scuba
diving she is working on getting her
scuba certification she is a major
coffee drinker she prefers a black and
she loves venture and comedy not to
mention singing and dancing Mike seems
like someone we want to hang out with
Emilia McCarthy Emilia is right in the
middle of her cast mates age wise but
she is anything but ordinary
this Virgo baby was born on August 28th
1997 virgos are spiritual people who
love to nurture friends and family
sometimes I can be shy and introspective
even if they're in the spotlight
their opposite sign is Pisces wait a
minute you remember when we said Milo is
a Pisces and Pisces tend to be attracted
to their opposites cool interesting
apparently her role in zombies was the
first term she got to sing in a film she
is also a fluent Spanish speaker she
shared in an interview that she is
actually half Mexican though she says no
one really believed her until she starts
speaking Spanish Amelia said that she
had a blast playing the extravagant mean
girl role of Laci in zombies but she
seems really nice in person James
Godfrey he might recognize James Godfrey
as Bonzo the character who is friends
with Zed and Eliza and only speaks
Dombey language his birthday is January
9th 1997 making him the third oldest
cast member James is a Capricorn which
makes him determined family oriented
responsible serious and a lover of music
the capricorns are kind of known for
bean know-it-alls
to the Music part sure seems to fit
James his character Bonzo can play over
32 instruments but James admits to being
an inexperienced dancer he said that the
four zombies
had never danced in his life James had
over 30 different odd jobs such as
nature guide pizza boy and youth pastor
before he finally landed on acting James
said he once did a comedy show but only
one person showed up that person is now
his wife uh-huh that's
sweet he also said he wants backpacked
in Algonquin by himself in November and
it was freezing and he can fully blow up
a balloon with one single breath kylie
russell the second oldest omni's cast
member on the list is Kylie Russell she
was born on October 28 1996 hmm that's a
few days away from Halloween kylie is a
Scorpio that means she can be
strong-willed and mysterious Kylie's
magnetic charm allows her to easily hold
the spotlight she's definitely equipped
to achieve her dreams don't you think
fun fact I'm Kylie loves to sing but we
bet you already knew that one Kylie is a
middle child
she loves cows and palm trees and her
favorite food is french toast
she's also a brilliant coder you can
catch her wearing two different earrings
any day because that's just her style
she said that while shearing is a new
thing she's very proud to be a zombie we
think we can speak for most when we say
she crushed it as Eliza in the film so
who's the oldest zombies cast member hmm
glad you asked Trevor Tordjman the
oldest cast mate on our list is Trevor
Tordjman can you guess his astrological
sign if you guessed Sagittarius you're
right he was born on November 22nd 1995
vegetarians are filled with optimism and
love learning new things well sometimes
they can be critical of others their
enthusiasm is contagious that pretty
much fits Trevor right this guy is an
incredible acrobat and dancer that much
we all know for sure but here are a few
things you may not have known his middle
name is Flanagan he's Canadian his
hometown is Kitchener in Ontario his
all-time favorite Disney movie is
Hercules because of the soundtrack he
watches home alone at least three times
every Christmas and he says he doesn't
want to live in a world where
yogurt-covered pretzels don't exist his
absolute favorite snack good to know
Trevor and those are our favorite
zombies cast members from youngest to
oldest thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]